hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action unleashes I'll be playing a
few games uh trying to trying to explain
the moves and uh the the thought process
behind the moves and hopefully those of
you who are trying to improve in at
chess will get something out of this uh
in my previous videos you guys said that
you uh really uh can learn from these
videos and I also get learn from them as
well uh sometimes if I like I took a
really bad beating in the French defense
two games in a row so I did brush up on
the French especially on the wi
variation uh so we'll see if that comes
in handy at any
point uh so yeah we're just going to
take the center with Pawn to E4 uh we
are playing against uh blv Kang Pam from
Vietnam and we're going to go for Knight
to F3 uh principal we attack a pawn
while developing and we're going to go
for Bishop to C4 many other moves are
possible he goes for Bishop to C5 and
for the moment uh we will be continuing
with the Evans Gambit as it is the
strongest move until we reach a point
where where maybe we have to improve the
Evans Gambit or yeah we're just
pressuring F7 here and depending on what
he does we will either Castle or Play
Bishop to E3 or maybe even Pawn to E5 um
so he has to decide how to give back uh
the material if he tries to cling onto
it maybe it's possible but it he could
run into some trouble so that's uh
that's for game plan here and uh if you
go something like Queen t7 yeah okay
we're we're just going to Castle then uh
he will be able to capture on e4 but
it's not really good due to Rook E1 and
if plays something like Queen E7 castles
and Knight F6 then we already have Pawn
to E5 with some Bishop to A3 action
these are standard Evans um standard
Evans Gambit moves uh that you can
always use and there's also something
like um uh maybe bishop to G5 where he
has to play F6 then we take the Knight
on G8 so uh all of this is uh possible
uh but as usual Bishop to B6 is the way
to go in these lines since it uh allows
for Knight to A5 Knight A5 pretty much
solves all of Black's problems in the
initial phase of the opening uh and then
black has to figure out how to develop
not sure if it's the way to go in this
particular setup okay so he even feels
comfortable grabbing another
Pawn
um uh yeah I don't know about
that uh since he has to figure out how
to deal with okay so he even gives up
the bishop so now this is long-term
Advantage for
me yeah he's uh being very brave
here yeah I don't think uh don't think
it's the best yeah even Queen F6 what is
this
H that is most
unusual
probably probably he hasn't faced the
Evans Gambit um that many times okay so
now uh Bishop to G5 looks okay but then
he has some Queen to B4 action so maybe
bishop to A3 is the way to go yeah
Bishop A3 let's just harass that
Queen and now he will have some some
serious problems
developing yeah he has to put the queen
all the way back to d8 and we can just
do
whatever yeah Queen d8
uh yeah the only way for him to develop
properly is Knight
H6 I'm really not buying Knight Knight
E7 so let's go Rook ad1 the famous
Anderson
move
uh now Knight H6 can even be met Knight
H6 I don't
know looks like uh a bit much since E6
could be an issue here if he goes Knight
H6 uh if he goes Knight
E7 yeah I'm just not buying any of this
yeah he goes Knight
H6 it's
nice really
nice
yeah we don't really have to react to
this I mean we could try some forcing
moves but we can just improve with Rook
e
one and uh
yeah like E6 maybe is a move maybe it
isn't like E6 he can just say okay I
mean now I mean how does he face
E6 like I want to play Rook D1 I
probably is it's the decent way to play
but I think just E6 is
fine yeah I don't know I do give up the
F6 Square so maybe now Queen F6 is a
move but I mean if if Queen F6 is a move
then then I I have no idea what I'm
doing yeah he claims Queen F6 is a move
most
interesting most
interesting
H yeah I'm even considering Rook E1 here
not going to play I'm just considering
it like if I play Rook E1 he captures my
queen is this is this anything yeah he
has King
d8 and uh yeah that's pretty much all
there is to
it
yeah I don't have 97 yeah I don't have
any any tricky
moves so I probably have to just capture
first yeah the problem is now I'm no
longer looking for ways
to yeah know just
uh
h
yeah if he takes the queen I can maybe
play this but then still King d8 not
much happening
there so what's
best yeah we'll take once we'll take
once uh
simply because if I move my queen yeah
also yeah that's maybe one of the
reasons why Rook D1 first was better I
thought the position was so overwhelming
that uh yeah just captures uh Ju Just U
playing like this would would be enough
but yeah probably rookie one was better
we'll see after the
game and the position is completely
winning now I I can win by just trading
queens and pushing the pawn no he will
take with the Knight very
interesting very interesting yeah let's
go Knight Knight E1 check rookie one
check and yeah
so H okay I will waste a few more
seconds looking for uh something like
something uh
Innovative but yeah just winning the the
Knight here is is
enough
yeah nothing nothing
better he does have two points for the
piece but he he's not really developed
uh yeah there's not much to to hope for
here yeah the Bishops are the Bishops
are absolute monsters here how does how
does he meet Bishop
B2 knight5
but now 95 also just gives gives up uh
more
material yeah
okay one way to do
it
um
huh
yeah let's uh let's hunt his
King let's hunt the
king now let's go
here a good King Hunt is always the way
to go let's go
here oh he's going to go there okay
we're going to offer a bishop
here we're going to offer a bishop for
[Music]
some for some Discovery
action and uh yeah if he takes it then
uh all of the all of the country chances
are
gone yeah it's
great uh what he's hoping to get in oh
he he's hoping yeah that that doesn't do
anything yeah Bishop G4 just Rook C1
check um it's nothing yeah Rook C1 check
and we just start
collecting um yeah okay let's go
back okay so he will still try to put
some resistance here but it's to no
avail yeah we're just going to start
picking up pawns
here yeah let's
uh let's take this
one and that's uh pretty much it now he
no longer has any any pawns to to go
along with his uh yeah let's kick away
that Bishop from there so just to give
our King some some breeding room so we
don't run into some sort of a tricky
move later
on yeah but we we are up a rook so
that's oh I almost uh yeah okay so I'll
allow him to to to skew my
Rooks uh again there's one check and
then we just move the Rook so it's not a
problem okay so he does it like let's go
for a nice check and uh yeah is there
anything anything nice here let's just
go after the
bishop yeah but we'll see what he we'll
see what he misplayed in the opening
there yeah that that whole Queen F6
business was uh was just too
much yeah
okay now
uh ah Rook D1 yeah Rook D1 yeah let's go
for a
check and now Bishop G7
check and and
uh yeah again not not the most precise
way
uh but yeah okay this is
uh can do it this way as
well and I we'll just start pushing
Pawns
yeah okay so you will go for
that it's just very hard to play since
there's nothing to
try Okay so he goes after the
pawn
uh okay let's eliminate this guy
here
yeah let's go here okay so now we just
start advancing our pawns we can even
give up the bishop we don't need the
bishop can't take it by yeah if he wants
it he can he can take
it not even going to defend
it yeah but he's uh taking it very
seriously playing every game to to to
the last possible
move as you always should so we should
learn something from Mr pong
Farm uh let's just start pushing those
pawns yeah okay we need the support of
the
king yeah probably there was a way yeah
you can have the bishop
sure probably there was a there was a
way to end the game effectively there
but uh yeah I've already ruined a couple
of games trying to be effective so yeah
better to better to just play moves that
you can
explain um yeah okay let's go push those
pawns let's go
here yeah okay so now he resigns good
game uh good game
Mr uh Mr Kong f now let's see what was
uh what was
the big idea okay so it was the Gambit
that uh he decided to retreat with
Bishop to A5 I strike I struck in the
center and went Queen to
B3 uh yeah okay going after F7 he play
Queen to E7 I castled he yeah Bishop to
B6 the move that we discussed if you
face the EV Gambit you absolutely have
to play Bishop to B6 it's uh it's
literally the only counter to the Evans
Gambit he went for captures and okay the
engine is already giving me like a plus
one uh since the Knight coming to D5 is
just a monster and now he captures I
captured and he has all sorts of dark
Square weaknesses here uh Queen F6 apply
D5 he went back apply Bishop to A3 yeah
and you can see that it's not really
difficult to exploit and I played Rook
ad D1 it's the top engine move I like to
call it the the underson move he played
Knight to H6 and I just played D6 yeah
everything is perfectly fine no the
engine wants to Capt trun
D7 uh for the for the reason of Rook e
one check and now after Bishop blocks
just Queen B3 okay I mean it's uh
definitely a way to play it yeah Knight
E7 Bishop
captures and now he has the castle and
he's down a piece but okay uh my way was
also him being down a piece so yeah not
really a problem captures captures and
Bishop captures there was no there was
no quick Checkmate or anything so I was
in the wrong there yeah but pretty much
it was a nice game nothing much to to
discuss after that yeah we went for the
king hunt as we should have yeah Rook
Rook C1 okay yeah we pick up the Rook
okay and after that I did allow him to
advance those pawns a little bit but uh
at this point you're no longer really
taking the game seriously since you're
you're up like a
100 uh but yeah uh you can see how one
little mistake against the Evans Gambit
the mistake being this
um uh this captures on C3 and it was uh
like like in the Anderson game you know
capturing on C3 it it's very ambitious
like maybe maybe in
um maybe you know in engine play it can
be done but I I think there were even
some games where Alpha zero completely
obliterated stockfish where stockfish
was forced to Capt on C3 and even
stockfish couldn't hold this position uh
so yeah that's the Gambit very easy uh
to to lose games but it's also very easy
to win games if your opponent makes uh
uh positional inaccuracy such as this
one uh so yeah that's the game I hope
you guys enjoyed it try the Evans Gambit
let me know how it goes for you and yeah
I will see you in the next one as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and uh we'll
see you in the next one see you
soon